mónica Langley why did you name your
book tearing down the walls because the
subject of the book sandy weill has
spent his entire life in the financial
industry tearing down walls when he
started on Wall Street it was run like a
club more than a business and he had to
break down barriers to even get on to
Wall Street and then when he made his
biggest acquisition of Citicorp and
created Citigroup the world's largest
financial empire he tore down the
glass-steagall and all the banking laws
in effect to put together this monster
his pictures on the screen tell us a
little bit about him he's a
larger-than-life figure he is he started
from nowhere and today is you know he's
the most important financial CEO in the
world
President Bush calls him to ask what he
sees in the economy Robert Rubin the
former Treasury secretary works for him
but at the beginning he was the person
least likely to succeed which is what's
so fascinating and you still see that
insecurity and worry and fear and loving
accolades even today now that he's a
billionaire here's a picture of him with
some golfers and one of those golfers is
Gerald Ford what's his role in all this
Gerald Ford was his first trophy
director when sandy first made his first
empire called Shearson he got Gerald
Ford after he was out of the presidency
to be a director and they have become
friends for 20 years and Gerald Ford has
become rich by holding the stock in
Sandy's companies and he's very
appreciative to sandy for that how did
he get bob rubin to work for him you
know that was a major coup as you know
everybody wanted bob rubin when he came
out of the Clinton administration and
sandy was sandy he can be a Salesman
from when he was selling little stocks
as a young man on Wall Street to today
he he would Rubin calling him every day
meeting with him every day for 30 days
and finally got Rubin to join on here's
a picture of three people he's in the
center James Robinson and they used to
hit up Americans press on the right the
one on the left is James Robinson's
second wife as you know and she used to
work for Republican National Committee
right Linda Gosselin Robinson it's a
great story between Jim Robinson and
Sandy Weill Jim Robinson is a patrician
chairman of American Express he brought
in sandy when he bought Shearson and
they were the exact opposites and they
could not get along and ultimately Jim
Robinson
on out over sandy weill over who would
control American Express and it was
Sandy's most public defeat in his career
but today they're friendly useful
bridges that this man in this picture
down here is the largest stockholder in
Citigroup that's right Prince Alwaleed
Prince Alwaleed of Saudi Arabia he holds
about 5% of Citigroup he's obviously one
of the richest men in the world and he
bought Citicorp stock originally in the
90s when the company was on its knees
and being practically run by the Fed and
today it's you know skyrocketed and when
Sandy went to visit him in the Saudi
desert he was trying to win a spot over
John Reid to take over Citigroup once
the men merged travelers in Citicorp
kind of drawn out but he's an important
figure so here he is dressed in Arab
garb exactly you say he's Jewish and
grew up in Brooklyn right Vincent Hearst
with an Arab in the desert and you say I
mean one of the themes of your book is
that being Jewish was difficult in on
Wall Street why would that be you know
it's it's really interesting to look
back in the 1950s it was a very waspy
place although there were some Jewish
firms like Goldman Sachs and others but
believe it or not those firms tended to
look down upon Eastern European Jews and
were more German Jewish so sandy is the
son of Polish immigrants and so he was
kind of the wrong kind of Jew but his
whole life has been a lot of class
struggle not just Jewish but coming for
having no connections no polish you know
and he's kind of had to have these class
struggles through his whole life here
he's pictured with former President
Clinton and and Jesse Jackson what's
this about interesting Jesse Jackson and
he are very close friends today Jesse
Jackson initially was going to oppose
one of Sandy's acquisitions in the early
90s and they met and at that point they
bonded over their shared discrimination
that they had felt growing up because
sandy felt discriminated against to some
degree Jesse Jackson did and was a civil
rights leader and so the two of them
bonded over several years and helped
each other it was a classic case of you
scratch my back I'll scratch yours Jesse
Jackson was able to start the wall
street project to move his Rainbow PUSH
coalition
to New York with Sandy's help so he
wanted to try to push to get more
minorities onto Wall Street and then
sandy in return backing of a huge civil
rights leader when he wanted to get
President Clinton in Congress to change
the banking laws to allow his huge
eighty three billion dollar merger in
1998 Jesse Jackson turned out to be an
important ally what degree of this was
that they shared discrimination or that
they shared money well sandy has sandy
and Citigroup have backed Jesse
Jackson's Wall Street project so you
know I mean there's been I mean sandy
does have the ability to I mean a
billionaire his company is the most
profitable one in the world so yes has
helped Jesse Jackson with his causes
financially so why should someone who
doesn't buy stock or pay any attention
to the stock market care about your book
what's in there in this book that they
can learn you know I think that Sandy's
life tells the story of Wall Street in
the financial industry for the last 50
years and broader than that though it
also tells the story of American society
because as you see the moves he's making
in business you also see American
society changing there's some things in
there about how he tried to help
Carnegie Hall and he was using that also
to break into the so-called white glove
society in New York you know from he was
new money versus old money so you will
see things about American history and
just the pure power of a personality and
how that person has changed financial
services and New York society Joe
Califano former HTW secretary and under
Lyndon Johnson
what role did he play in this company he
was a director and he you know he and
Sandy are not really close however he he
came on the board when sandy bought
traveler's so they got to know each
other then and he is the one who advised
sandy when sandy was taking over
travelers get out of the health care
business it's going to be full of
politics Hillary Clinton is coming on
the scene so he was instrumental in
having sandy get out of what turned out
to be a very troubled business he'd and
he just fired him from the board just
like that yeah
sandy as you will say he expects loyalty
but sometimes he's not always as loyal
to the people
you know who worked for him or with him
and Joe Califano took it nicely though
when he led him off the board you know
he said okay I've done well with this
company I understand other directors who
were longtime friends didn't like sandy
shoving them aside as he was moving up
the ladder Frank Zarb former energy
secretary on the board or on a played a
role in well yeah he you know what he
was the one who sandy first hired in the
1960s in the early 70s to set up a back
office which turned out to be
Sandy's ticket to success on Wall Street
because sandy was never able to walk in
the front door because the Wall Street
wouldn't let him in to schmooze with the
brokers and he had no contact so we had
to go in the back door and work in the
back office he started as a runner at
Bear Stearns in the 1950s even though he
had a college degree and he learned the
back office and so then when he got
control of a little firm a two office
firm that he started with three others
Arthur Levitt being one of them he knew
he needed to set up a back office and he
brought in Frank Zarb and they always
joked that they were nobodies and they
ended up doing very well financially and
Frank Zarb appears in and out through
this book in several of Sandy's
companies former CIA director John
Deutsch he is a was a loyalist to John
Reed he was on the City Court Board and
in 1998 sandy proposed to John Reed in a
hotel room here in DC when they were
here for a business council meeting
let's merge our two companies which was
a totally audacious unbelievable idea
John Deutsch was on the board of
Citicorp and when John Reed and Sandy
Weill ultimately fought with each other
over who would control Citigroup in the
year 2000 John Deutsche was a supporter
of John Reed which one which person in
this picture is John Reed the one right
there yeah that one and where is he
today he's very happy out of the company
I mean he lost a bruising battle to
Sandy there was a boardroom showdown in
2000 and he lost he thought that sandy
had promised the two of them would merge
their companies and leave together John
Reed was ready to retire and sandy
wasn't say the outmaneuvered him the
entire time John Reed today has a house
in the south of France and he teaches
some and speaks and he's very happy he
sold Citigroup stock when it was very
high
and he's a happy man not worrying with
the latest stock gyrations and what the
market expects city to do
how old is sandy weill said he just
turned 70 March 16th and his title today
he's chairman and CEO of Citigroup and
he has no intention of giving it up
anytime soon when most men would be or
women at the heads of corporations would
be going to the golf course he is
committed to stay there until he
basically salvages his reputation and
Citigroup after the bruising fall this
past year they've had with the Wall
Street scandals
how big a company is Citigroup Citigroup
has a trillion dollars in assets it's a
market capitalization of nearly 200
billion it is one of the top five
largest companies US companies and the
biggest financial conglomerate in the
world where is it physically located
it's based in New York City on Park
Avenue and but it is in 100 countries I
mean it is truly it's and sandy wants to
make it make it what a McDonald's or a
coke is all over the world so it stands
for financial services
what is it owned what is it a lot
apart from Citibank which you'll see on
it's not everywhere but you see it on
every street corner in New York City it
also it did own travelers and recently
divested travelers which was a big
insurance company it also owns city
cards did you know that 20% or 25% of
all credit cards are from Citibank in
this country so a lot of people watching
probably have a city card it owns city
financial which makes consumer loans
they've obviously named everything City
these days and then they have something
called PFS which are independent
insurance agents that sell to the middle
class so what they what Sandy's vision
has been for a couple decades is to
create a financial empire that hits
every market and provides you every
service his famous cross-selling where
does he personally live he has an
apartment in Manhattan
on Fifth Avenue he has a mansion in
Greenwich Connecticut and then he has a
weekend place in the Adirondack
Mountains in upstate New York and he's
just completing a like a lavish yacht
that he sold one yacht ins getting a
bigger yacht how many children does him
he has two chilled
it's unmarked and a daughter Jessica
they're both in their 40s and they have
both worked in and out of their father's
companies - some controversy over the
years sandy used to say he was in favor
of nepotism today he'll tell you he's
not Jessica whose pictures right here
you say it was a the moment there's a
moment in the book that seems to be an
important moment when a man named Jamie
Dimon would not promote her within one
of sandy wiles companies yeah Jamie
Dimon was Sandy's heir apparent and
almost like a son to him he was the
alter ego and he had started as an
assistant straight out of Harvard
Business School with Sandy Weill they
had they built Citigroup together sandy
really wanted to promote Jessica she is
the apple of his eye
and she's very savvy marketer she wanted
to head up all of the mutual funds and
investment management and Jamie did not
think she was ready for the job and
didn't think she should do it he thought
she should go out in the field and get
some experience and when Jamie refused
to do that and Jessica left the company
sandy and Jamie's relationship was never
the same
and Jamie ultimately was gone how much
time have you personally spent with
Sandy while I first met him three or
four years ago when I wrote a page one
article for The Wall Street Journal on
him and then on this book I spent about
two and a half years on it and I would
see sandy at least once a month but this
is not his authorized biography it's an
independent project so I interviewed 500
people but clearly I wanted to resonate
with who sandy you know eight with Sandy
and so people would recognize him so I
tried to spend as much time as he would
allow although he went back and forth
with me because he couldn't control the
project so sometimes he'd feel like
cooperating and sometimes he wouldn't
but I stayed ahead and ultimately got
unprecedented access within city now if
you read your book you can figure out
often who talked to you uh-huh
I won't say I mean I some people are
acknowledged as sources you know but a
lot of people didn't want to be
acknowledged as sources although
everyone knew I would be describing it
and writing it as as a narrative you
know to say what they were doing
thinking talking so you probably can see
and there's
people in the back I thank for being
critical sources let me just read a
quote this is one and I want to ask you
to talk about okay the subject matter
you're not loyal this isn't quotes
you're not loyal you sob you didn't say
it he said the fourth yeah
Sandi reacted vociferously you should
show me blood loyalty cut your wrists
kind of lowly you didn't support me this
is around page 81 I think you're talking
about Cohen yeah Peter Paulo
who was his deputy in building his first
empire and that was when sandy was
trying to get ahead and get some
position at American Express he was the
president without a portfolio and Jim
Robinson the CEO was basically running
things and had the board locked up so
this really kind of shows you the
behind-the-scenes stuff that you see you
think big business is decided by looking
at the bottom line or a ledger and
they're sitting here having a fight like
brothers about you're not loyal to me
you sob and you know sandy really
expected him to slit his wrists at one
point and another scene in the book the
executives go off and they're all
fighting with each other and some of
them go in the kitchen and actually
slice their fingers and you know have
like a blood oath that they're gonna be
together so sandy takes everything
personally that's one of his strengths
and one of his weaknesses on the page
before that this is before Cohen could
explain sandy launched into a tirade
screaming you don't know what the f
you're talking about
you better not challenge me on this yeah
there aren't many people who could have
told you that yeah well if there were
people in I mean I acknowledge in the
book that you know I talked to both
Sandy Weill and Peter Cohen and so I
would obviously try to run anything by
them and make sure that it's accurate
also there were people who would have
heard that in a meeting or at the bar I
don't remember exactly which one that
was but there could be other people who
heard it at the time or we're told it
immediately after and you know that I
did reconstruct dialogue in the book to
try to make it real so you feel like
you're there and I did it in a
painstaking fashion of trying to check
it with the people who were there in the
room who were participants or who were
told immediately thereafter about it
to make it as as real as I possibly
could I mean there's always chances
there could be a word or two wrong or
whatever but I did reconstruct dialogue
and tried to do it with a huge amount of
accuracy back to the lifestyle at some
point the book you talk about planes how
often does he use a helicopter to get to
work how often you know he uses it
whenever it's convenient I mean if he
wants to bop down to Washington he'll
take the helicopter or if he wants to go
he when he was at travelers and then he
would want to go stop in Greenwich or
back to Manhattan he would use it I mean
he uses whatever is convenient he adores
however his Gulfstream it was a g4 I
guess now it's a g5 he's a jet the
luxury jet and you know in one part when
he was trying to buy Smith Barney he
didn't like that the the seller of Smith
Barney
had these golden parachutes but if he
was going to give up the golden
parachutes by God he wanted that
Gulfstream that was on order you know so
you can see sandy loves his perks and
you see that throughout that he can be I
mean he's like a slice you up cut cut
cost everywhere you know when he took
over one company he took out the coffee
pots he made the water their own plants
and then he goes to these elaborate
dinners at night where there's you know
four different kinds of wine six courses
you know so he I mean he would argue
that his perks help him do business and
develop the camaraderie with the senior
management or with the clients or the
people he's doing deals with Four
Seasons restaurant that is almost a
character in and of itself in the book
there's a couple places that are real
characters one is Carnegie Hall and I
think the other is the Four Seasons
restaurant it is the scene of the true
power lunch
you know the origination of the power
lunch was with the Four Seasons
restaurant and Sandi goes there because
he loves to see and be seen and when he
was ousted from American Express and was
in corporate exile for a year and a half
he took an office in the building that
the Four Seasons restaurant is in so he
wouldn't feel out of the action so he
could go down and have a big lunch and
have his two martinis and he would see
the power players and he would be one he
got a call I'm not sure I remember for
sure but he gave this man right here
gave him a call was it during the time
that he didn't have
job you know he had started when he was
with American Express you know that gave
him an a premature of the establishment
and so he went on the carnegie hall
board at the time and then when he was
out of american express he was afraid
that carnegie hall wouldn't want him
anymore he didn't have a position he's
so identified with his company that he
never thought he was worthy in and of
himself so he was he got a phone call
from isaac stern and he thought oh my
god he's getting ready to ask me to
leave the board so he volunteered i'll
leave the board and isaac stern said no
i'm calling you know he's a Fame
violinist isaac stern said no i'm
calling to tell you we want you more
than ever
and actually carnegie hall turned out to
be sandy salvation when he was in
corporate exile in the mid 80s because
it allowed him he was raising funds for
carnegie hall but he got to go out and
see people and talk to the powers that
need to try to get their money and it
gave him something to do because he
literally was sitting there watching a
quote on for a year and a half trying to
do deals and nothing was happening now
it seems to me that if he sat there and
watch that quilt Ron everyday you he had
to tell you that or either that or his
assistant assistant Allison fall yeah
Allison Falls was his assistant and
Jamie Dimon was his assistants but in
different capacities Jamie Dimon today
is where Jamie Dimon today is the
chairman and CEO of bank 1 in Chicago
the nation's fifth or sixth largest bank
and he got that job after being in
corporate exile himself when sandy fired
him in 1998 after finally making the big
deal in buying Citicorp sandy fired
Jamie in what was a very gut wrenching
incident within the company because
everybody viewed them so together and
then Jamie it took him a year so to pick
a job and get the right job and he's now
in Chicago and people today think he
wants to make a Wall Street place so
badly you know to compete against city
or in Sandy or they send people quietly
hoping that one day he'll come back and
run City when sandy finally exits go
back to the loyalty thing how many
people that he expected loyalty to him
from did he fire over the years start
naming the ones that you can think that
there's a stream of names for one thing
Frank Zarb you talked about at one point
he kicked Frank's are about out to bring
in Bob Greenhill who
didn't work out a big star investment
banker he he basically shouldn't pushed
aside Peter Cohen didn't technically
fire him but basically pushed him aside
then you can go you know john reed who
he's promised a you know great marriage
at citigroup ultimately he pushed him
out jamie dimon those are the most
obvious names but it's happened a lot
whether it's a director or someone who
worked for him
I mean people realized suddenly they say
you know you're not getting phone calls
from Sandy's not returning your call you
realize you're on your way out and some
people just decide to go or sometimes he
fires them why does he think then people
ought to be loyal to him I mean it seems
to me in reading your book that no one
that worked for him should have ever
felt at anytime that they couldn't be
next yeah I think that's true and I
think that that scene he uses that to
his advantage because he wants them to
feel on their toes and feel like they
got to perform for him he pushes people
in the most dramatic fashion I mean they
are I was calling people and reporting
this but they were in their office at
five o'clock in the morning these are
people that are multimillionaires at six
o'clock in the morning multimillionaires
running huge empires within Citigroup
and he uses that to advantage to make
them want to perform the best as they
possibly can and there is a thing about
sandy even though he can be a big bully
and can be vicious he also can be
charming and have a really sweet side to
him believe it or not and as as a writer
working on this book I felt both sides
of his personality myself there's a
quote on page 71 not bad for a kid from
Brooklyn he confided to a friend
the Jews are going to take over American
Express and they'll never know what hit
them
who said that sandy said that why would
he say something like that you know the
American Express I called the chapter in
the book in the wasp nest it truly was a
wide an anglo-saxon Protestant Empire
and the board was very much the Palm
Beach you know private club set
and so you could the differences were so
stark between sandy and his team you
know like Frank's arm and Peter card all
started with nothing versus the
button-down guys who came from privilege
you know Jim Roberts
and was the third or fourth line banker
from Atlanta his family was very well
known so I don't know what provoked
sandy to say that but he used class
struggle to his advantage all the time
you know it if it were if it weren't
June versus wasp and not that he was
doing it overtly you know it would be
things like the rich versus poor or
entrepreneur versus establishment he
felt very entrepreneurial going into
American Express and they were very
establishment and they wanted to send
memos and he he doesn't read memos so he
wasn't performing the American Express
way you know so a lot of these things he
uses to his advantage and they've been
powerful motivators to him above that
with thousands of his employees
listening sandy sobbed openly and you've
you often cite that he breaks down and
cries yeah that is the that's one of the
endearing qualities he can be a really
tough guy that you don't want to cross
and then he has so much emotion that you
know when he sold Shearson and he wanted
to he announced to his company that he
had built from nothing he broke down and
cried there a few times as you say in
the book where he does break down and
cry he told me when he read the last
chapter of this book he broke down and
cried so he's he is an emotional guy you
know if he's mad and you know if he's
happy so what's his reaction to your
book mixed his first reaction was he had
it he wanted to you know he's a control
freak all these people in powerful
positions are and he first wanted to
when he couldn't control the book then
he wanted the galleys when it was
written I wouldn't give him the galleys
then he wanted like the first copy he
kept calling me right before it came out
and I said no I finally I said I will
give you one of the first copies that I
get off the presses you know you are the
subject to the book I'll do that so he
was at a senior management retreat you
know he likes to go on these retreats he
was down in the Bahamas he had a car a
driver come to my house at 7 o'clock on
Friday morning on a Friday morning in
February two weeks before the book came
out I just got my copies to pick it up
and put it on the Gulfstream jet they
were flying down spouses and it's a
couple other executives so he and a
couple of his key people could read it
over the weekend I they came back after
the weekend I heard it was more popular
than golf getting people are canceling
the golf matches and I talked to him and
several others and his reaction it said
he said it would be a great read if it
weren't about me but there's a lot of
things he doesn't like in it and can you
tell us some of those things he doesn't
like okay he doesn't like some of the
points that I make about the class
struggle you know I mean he really
doesn't like Singh neck all laid out or
some of the personal idiosyncrasies of
his of like you know that when he was in
exile and I have him sleeping on the
couch at the in his office above the
four seasons and he was drinking and
eating a lot and I have him sleeping on
the couch with the tufted leather couch
on his cheek and you know slums running
out his mouth he's like why do you have
to put that you know he doesn't like
some of those things and I told him I
had to bring you to life I felt my
mission in writing this book was to even
though this is the world's largest
financial empire is to show what one man
does like him or hate him you'll see
what he does and I wanted to bring him
to life and I had to bring out his
humanists to me to make it readable to
my family in Tennessee or to you know
the canyons of Wall Street I wrote down
some things that you said about him
a voracious social climber mmm-hmm he
loves to be seen see each other see the
people feel part of them he always I
mean for a while there he was in the New
York Times society page like every other
week if there was a an honor to be given
in the last few years he wanted it why
did he want this award so much that is
CEO of the Year award and you know
people that preceded him were Michael
Dell Jack Welch you know big heavy
hitters and it's not just the financial
service its CEO of the year that meant a
lot to him he wanted that for the last
few years and he was afraid he wasn't
gonna get it and when they called him to
tell him it see that he was going to get
CEO of the year he started shivering he
was so excited and here this man this
was just this past summer and he was so
excited he's shivering he flies in his
mother-in-law from California who never
wanted Joan to marry sandy never want
her daughter to marry him and it was a
very big deal of course as you know
in the book that very night that he's
getting the honor he had coveted for so
long his whole crisis his whole career
is breaking in front of him that exact
same day and what is that that is the
testimony on Capitol Hill of Jack
Grubman who was his 20 million dollar a
year telecom analyst and Jack Grubman
was testifying
you know Enron WorldCom these are gone
bankrupt worse and worse scandal-ridden
and Citigroup
Salomon Smith Barney that's another
thing I should have mentioned earlier
that he owes Salomon Smith Barney was
the key banker for these institutions
and Grubman was the analyst and the
banker on on the transactions so Grubman
was hauled in to Washington to testify
about his involvement so sandy is
sitting on the floor of the New York
Stock Exchange about to win this award
you know everybody's chattering it's
cocktail hour it's beautiful black-tie
gala and on the TV screens on the New
York Stock Exchange floor they keep
airing the congressional testimony of
Grubman so sandy is sitting there about
to win the biggest award and he can't
help but notice over his shoulder are
the TV screens where Jack Grubman is
saying they said did you favor big
clients over small investors and you
know Sandy's rise had come through
smaller investors Lisa did you favor big
big clients you know the big cats
instead of the small investor and Jack
Grubman is like I don't know I don't
know if I did that maybe you know it was
a very evasive dismal performance and
sandy literally broke out in a sweat
that night as this was going on so what
kind of fine did city city is it's not
final yet but they negotiated in
December that the 1.3 billion dollar
settlement for all the securities
industry and Citigroup will pay the
largest amount 400 million in fine and
other restitution I should say this is
being taped and early April in case
things change between yeah now that you
say that that he was emotional about the
last chapter in this book well that a
lot of you're talking about here's in
the last chapter right why was the
emotional you know because it really
showed him going back to like his core
of having to be you know the last few
years he's been like a Globetrotter you
know I mean that's one of the other
things that he loves is is getting a big
reputation and
going and learning about China I mean a
kid from Brooklyn now doing all this
stuff and he he had to with this crisis
going in the stock of Citigroup
plummeted I mean forty percent just in
you know a three-month period it lost a
whopping 100 billion dollars in market
value that's a lot and so suddenly he
was on the fence he was having to defend
his reputation and his company and he
kind of went back to the core
he had gotten fat and happy kind of he
lost 30 pounds I call it the Spitzer
diet named after Eliot Spitzer the New
York Attorney General and he started
reading everything again and not reading
so much but talking about everything
wanting to check everything and at the
end when it's finally over in the
initial settlement is announced he says
let's go back to work and it's like I've
got to do it all over again you know
Here I am having to prove my critics
wrong again and I think what he was
emotional about was there's a scene near
the end where his top in top management
is at a gathering in one of their
retreats in California and Sandy speaks
look we've screwed up we've got to do
better we've got to get back on course
because they weren't going for every
part of the business and we got to step
back look what's best for a Wall Street
not just for our bottom line and when he
finishes talking he walks into the crowd
and they all rush and basically circle
him and he disappears in the crowd and
that was an emotional thing for him and
I guess reading it made him feel
emotional again why are they so
emotional about it if he hasn't been
loyal to his top people over the years
well for one thing that's the thing they
this is what I found out Ron it's not
it's not an easy thing with Sandy you
don't love him or hate him even the
people that are his best friends
strongly dislike certain things about
him even people who hate him
admire certain qualities of his so a lot
of these key executives feel strongly
that he is leading them you know to
greatness I mean the company is a great
company at the same time they're all
getting very rich one person said to me
you know you hate it the whole time
you're getting wealthy I mean these
people all have stock options sandy was
one of the first believers in stock
options back in the 80s
and so people have stuck with him you
know from even secretaries to a
chauffeur can be a millionaire in his
empire if they've stuck with him from
the beginning
you say that Bob Rubin who came out of
the Secretary of Treasury job here in
Washington got a 33 million dollar year
package to work for him and not have any
line responsibilities that's right
explain that well that's that's
interesting because Rubin did not want
to go and be a hands-on manager again
you know he had run goldman sachs before
he went to be the treasury secretary he
was such a big get you know Rubin was so
highly sought after and he gives so much
cachet to any company who got him
they're willing to give him a very
lucrative package he does bring things
to the table though I mean Citigroup
last year bought Banamex one of the two
largest banking empires in Mexico and
that was done because the Mexican banker
called Bob Rubin and said well I'm
thinking about we may be wanting to sell
our bank and so sandy and Rubin got on a
helicopter flew down to Mexico City got
on a helicopter and went to a Hacienda
in Mexico and worked out a deal in 24
hours to buy this huge banking
institution in Mexico which is going to
be key with the cross country between
Mexico and the United States how much of
that came from Bob Rubens time at the
Secretary of Treasury job oh that was
clearly part of it because he helped
negotiate Mexico and during its
financial crisis
what does Gerald Ford do for him and how
much did he do for Gerald Ford II I mean
idea how much money he made off of this
board membership oh yeah yeah I you know
no I don't know the total amount that he
made but he I didn't meet with with
Gerald Ford in the presidential suite at
the Waldorf Hotel when he was in for a
board meeting with Citigroup to
interview him for the book and he did
tell me that he has set up press for his
family things for from Citigroup stock
and he's very appreciative because as
you know a lifelong politician like Ford
would not have that much wealth so he's
done well I can't quantify though I
don't how do use him oh my gosh well he
used him as his trophy I mean he would
trot him out he gave him the kind of
credibility that he really hadn't had
you know when he was ousted from a mare
can express he basically had to start
over and Gerald Ford was one of his
first big board members when then he
acquired this dinky consumer finance
company called commercial credit in
Baltimore he first put forward on
Shearson in 1980 and then he brought him
back to be on the board in 1986 when he
bought another company so Ford helped
him just in the credibility and Sandy
would work him you know having him go to
companies and talk to brokers and
clients and things like that so he did
have a role and it was mostly now I do
know in some board meetings he would ask
Ford at the dinner the night before
board meeting what's your opinion on
what's happening you know in politics in
government things like that so he would
ask for questions how much money does he
pay himself every year
this year he just had him adjust a
million dollar he took a million dollar
salary and he refused a bonus because
the stock did so poorly but a couple
years ago he made over two hundred
million dollars if you can opt his his
salary his bonus and the exercise of his
stock stock off how much is he worse
he is worth he was worth more before the
Wall Street crisis happened last fall he
was getting close to two billion now
he's in the billion plus range that's
his worth based on Citigroup stock and
most of his wealth is tied up in
Citigroup stock which is why he says
he's not like you know some of these
people who cashed out of their companies
right before they went down he his
wealth is intricately involved with how
well the company does or doesn't do and
what role does his wife play in all this
I called Joan the most important merger
of his career and that's pretty
significant because he's probably done
hundreds of murders big and small she
was the one who believed in him when no
one would her parents didn't want her to
marry him when they met in their early
20s and they married early in life and
she has stuck with him and she is the
ultimate corporate wife you know we've
seen a lot of them over years and she
truly is she has stayed with him through
thick and thin and bucks him up when he
when he is really down and
she also gives him I found out a lot of
savvy advice particularly about people
who should trust or not trust so
executives tell me she's very much a
power behind the scenes how long have
you been with The Wall Street Journal
over a dozen years I started with the
journal in 83 after I got out of
Georgetown Law School and was with the
journal until 89 and then left to go
practice law to try that for a few years
and I rejoined the journal in 96 why did
you do that well you know I discovered
the 88 presidential campaign which is
grueling and I just got married
and I thought maybe I want to practice
law make more money you know have a
different kind of life see if I like it
because I did enjoy law school and I did
enjoy it and I'm glad I did it because
now it makes me a better journalist
because when I'm interviewing people and
work and understand from their
perspective because I represented
clients who were in the press and who
had to face crises and so I really
understand more of how they're doing it
now practice corporate law which is
helpful to me as a Wall Street Journal
reporter to understand more than just
the basics where did you practice
corporate law in Knoxville Tennessee I
went home to my hometown you grew up in
Knoxville from that years two years were
you there let's see how was born in 58
so I stayed there and went to the
University of Tennessee graduated with
the journalism major then came to
Georgetown I only looked at to law
schools really Columbia in Georgetown
because I still thought I wanted to be a
journalist in New York in Washington
were very good journalism towns and
really liked Washington when I came to
visit Georgetown and so did that then I
moved to New York for the Wall Street
Journal I covered AT&T and
telecommunications it's more than one
know then moved back here covered
Congress and banking regulators in the
presidential campaign
then practice law and then move back to
New York to be with the Wall Street
Journal I've written then writing page
one stories for The Journal since 96
who's this fellow Roger Wallace my
husband he's with CBS and that was
another reason we moved back to New York
because he can obviously be involved
with the network right there in New York
City and the Wall Street Journal's in
New York and so he was really the one
who like carried a lot of the borough
of home and we have a four-year-old
daughter so he helped tremendously this
book wouldn't have been possible without
his being you know there to hold things
down even though he had a full-time job
because once I started writing it's such
a solitary process and it's so consuming
and especially on sandy weill who as
we've talked about has his he can go hot
and cold with people and he did with me
so sometimes I would feel miserable you
know am I ever gonna get him to open up
about this or what am I gonna do and
sometimes I would feel so high you know
that I've really nailed this I've got it
and so Roger was there with me as a
fellow journalist kind of knowing when I
was going through so when did you feel
the biggest high after talking to Sandy
while I never felt the biggest high
after talking to Sandy it wasn't any
conversations with sandy it would be
when I felt that I really knew the
inside of what happened that I got it
when was it oh gosh there were several
times the biggest high I think one key
time was when the board I really felt
like I understood what happened at the
board meeting there was a huge show that
woman that between John Reed and Sandy
Weill of who would control the world's
largest financial empire and Bob Rubin
turned out to be key there and you
really saw these people they were the
directors they're some of the biggest
companies in the world are on the city
court board Citigroup org and they ended
up deciding things based on ego John
Reed's ego or sandy really wants the job
so bad should we let him have it
has he misled us and you get to see how
ego ambition greed petty sometimes petty
things and other times very basic human
emotions can be important in what
happens in a financial empire or in
corporate America so that was one of the
times when I felt like I'd really gotten
what happened to show I want to show a
reader kind of like a fly on the wall
you know how what's it like if you were
that in the room and someone actually
called me afterwards I said even though
I knew how it came out
I was reading it with bated breath what
was going to happen next and to me
that's a great compliment when people
like kind of know who won but you're
still want to read and see how did it
happen is there anybody that you tried
to talk to in this that wouldn't talk to
you
you know almost everybody talked to me
there were a few people that did not
talk to me but none that I think were
Sookie that I feel the book is not
representative I mean John Reid is a key
character and he did not want to
cooperate he wanted Citigroup out of his
life and he was glad to be gone I did
see him and chat with him on different
things that I pushed yeah John Reid is
the one on the left yeah Bob Rubin on
the right Sandy Weill in the middle John
Reid on the left and his job again was
when this all started he was the
chairman and CEO of Citicorp he is a
legendary banker all the ATM's you see
on every street corner is because of
John Reid he had the technological
vision to do that any put Citicorp into
a hundred countries so sandy really when
he proposed travelers his insurance and
securities empire merged with Citicorp
he was getting the benefit of a great
institution that had been around a long
time it had trouble but before John read
it was Walter Wriston it so it's a
legendary Bank and back in the days when
Sandy was trying to break in on Wall
Street you know he would see the city
court building you know the city bank
building which has legends of Finance
around it you know and they were
shutting the doors on sandy Wow
so Citicorp was very important to sandy
it was what he called the mother of all
deals if he could ever do that then he
would have succeeded and John Reed was
his way to get Citicorp he got John Reed
to agree but then in the boardroom
showdown we talked about he got rid of
him what year this was in 2000 spring of
2000 how long did it take for him to get
rid of in two years at first they had a
great honeymoon you know it was a very
quick courtship but they were cozy oh
yes they were co-chairman and co-ceos
and sandy proposed that he said let's do
this together we won't we'll share power
and both when they took the deal to
their board the City Court Board and the
Travelers board the boards were like oh
my god are you kidding you both have
huge egos you both have rent used to
running your own shows this will never
work and Reed and Sandy Weill told them
yes it will we've known each other for
30 years we'll make it work so they had
it they just they did this deal the
at the time it was the biggest murder
ever 83 billion dollars they did it in
six weeks negotiated only by them in a
couple close aides they didn't want to
involve anyone else because they didn't
want you to leak out because there would
be a lot of potential opposition to this
deal because they were breaking down
barriers in financial services and then
at the beginning they were very
lovey-dovey you know they were in a
honeymoon oh sandy you're so good at
operations Reid would say what do you
say
and then sandy would say to Reid oh
you're so good at strategy what do you
think so they were all lovey-dovey but
when it got down to the nitty-gritty of
running this day in and day out they
were so different
they couldn't coexist and then it became
a struggle so how do you do it he
basically he just put his nose to the
grindstone and grindstone and got all
his people in the most powerful
operational positions see John Reid was
getting tired of basically running
things worrying about the bottom line
worrying about the stock price he said
we should say though that they used you
point out that they agreed to retire
they fought at the same time or at least
John Reid Oh John Reid thought that they
would put this deal together and then
leave as soon as the deal was solid as
soon as the merger had happened and it
was working well John Reid understood
that they would leave together
sandy apparently never told him oh no
that's wrong but he never told him oh
yes that's right and there's one scene
on the night the night before the deal
is to be announced on you know in New
York Sandy's loyal General Counsel
notices some language in a filing that
says and then when the deal is done they
will leave together and he calls John
Rietz lawyer the night before the deals
to be announced and says wait a minute
this isn't the deal and John Reed's
lawyer says it is the deal and that's
what John tells me and Sandy's person
said you may think they're gonna ride
into the sunset together
but sandy hasn't told me that and at
that point they would stop the whole
deal and they said well it's not really
imperative that it be in this SEC filing
so we'll take it out but that was the
beginning when John Reid should have
been aware that sandy really never
intended to leave so quickly
this is Sandy's life he loves his work
who's on that board now let's see bob
rubin is on that board there you know
Gerald Ford is still on the board
interestingly Reuben Marc the Chairman
and
CEO of Colgate Palmolive has just
decided to go off the board he was on
the Citicorp original board and he has
become so frustrated with Sandy when
when they did ask John Reed in 2000
sandy committed that within two years he
would the successor would be in place or
the process would be working and that
was how they were to stroke each other's
ego
well John we're not just picking sandy
overuse just sandy will have to leave at
some point and here it is 2003 Sandy's
not leaving he doesn't have a clear
successor in fact he loves to confuse
who might be his heir apparent
so Ruben Marc at a recent board meeting
said to the board this very elite board
look don't we need to be talking about
successors we can't just leave this to a
little committee we've got it this is
one of the biggest jobs we need to do
what if something happens to Sandy
tomorrow and the board's like let's
leave it to the committee and in
frustration Ruben Marc the chairman of
Colgate Palmolive has recently decided
not to stand for re-election for the
board his prints al well lead on the
board no he's not on the board and he
owns seven billion dollars worth of
stock yeah you know it's 5% of City and
he is not on the board does he not want
to be on the board you know he hasn't
expressed any interest and I did
interview him for the book and obviously
if he calls Sandy Weill or Bob Rubin
they'll take his call but he says he's a
passive investor and that it's done well
for him so I don't I don't know that he
doesn't keep he knows everything when
it's happening though they keep him
abreast go back to the array he
originally invested 500 some million
right what year was that that was in
1991 I think I may be off a little but
it was in the early 90s when Citigroup
Citicorp was really having a lot of
trouble and because of the third world
losses and things like that the company
was doing poorly go back to the jack
Grubman story again Jack Grubman was who
what was his job that Grubman was an
analyst and for Salomon Smith Barney and
an analyst is supposed to write what
companies to invest in for their
millions of investors and his expertise
was telecommunications so he was touting
WorldCom like crazy
unbeknownst to the investing public he
was also advising WorldCom on what to do
and was very close to the CEO none of
this came out until the stock market
plummets in the last year or so and then
you have investors and regulators and
politicians looking for who to blame we
invested tons of money in WorldCom today
it's worthless it's bankrupt and then
you start unraveling and finding Jack
Grubman was a key player telling
investors to buy in royal calm even as
it was tanking and he was advising let
me ask me though about the AT&T thing
Mike Armstrong was a member of the board
of Citigroup
correct and Sandy Weill was a member of
the board of AT&T correct and you know
that's happened a lot in years past
where directors are on each other sports
the question became here that sandy the
one stock that Grubman what was
criticizing was a tea sandy was on the
board of a tea and he would he wanted
Grubman to quit being so down on a TMT
sandy and Armstrong believed in a tea
now they were on each other's boards as
you note so finally Grubman gives so
finally Grubman improves his rating when
sandy says take a fresh look now sandy
says that he never told Bremen what to
write in his reports however I guess a
lot of people say if your boss tells you
take a fresh look and you know he's on
the 18 T board you know he wants you to
say something good
Grubman did change his rating to a
positive one on 18 t then a and T and
then Salomon Smith Barney got more
business underwriting AT&T stock and
other securities offerings and then when
everything kind of broke down the emails
were discovered that Grubman was writing
to people at the time I changed my
rating on AT&T to help sandy win the
battle with John Reed and get
Armstrong's vote and because then sandy
would help get my kids into influential
preschool 90-second y 92nd Street Y one
of the posh preschools in Manhattan 170
kids at the school yeah I mean it's you
know probably cost ten thousand dollars
a year to send your child you're taught
good Citigroup or Sandy Weill give that
school a million dollar
Citigroup gave that school a million
dollars in grubman's behalf on grubman's
behalf how can that happen though I mean
if I'm a stockholder of Citigroup what
are they doing giving a million dollars
to that school
well apparently sandy did make a call to
the 92nd Street Y and say you know if
you could help grubman's kids get in
grubman sandy did not know that he says
he did not know the content of the
emails and that Grubman was changing his
rating to get Sandy's help sandy said he
helped Grubman just because he was a
valued employee and Grubman said will
you make a call to 92nd Street Y I know
who you know is more important than
anything in the in New York City and
obviously Sandy Weill had become a big
name so sandy called and then he said
and look Citigroup will help out and he
gave a million dollar donation now they
view it I talked to directors this is
very you know unusual thing to have
occurred and I did speak to directors
and they say it was presented to them as
additional compensation from Grubman to
give him an additional million dollars
but here Grubman was making twenty
million dollars a year he really could
have made his written his own million
dollar cheque but it meant more coming
from sandy wiles Citigroup and that's
why it was given how much time do you
think people would give Sandy Weill if
he wasn't the CEO of this company and
wasn't worth the kind of money's worth
gosh that's the great who knows but
what's your suspicion after talking to
people on having them level with you
behind the scenes you know there are a
lot of people that when he was under
fire and on the front pages of the
newspaper that were privately cheering I
mean there are a lot of people that he
has crossed and done deals who you know
don't like him and think it's time for
him to get his come up and seem to get
what he deserves there are other people
that still think it's very unfair he's
got a lot he's given a lot of charitable
contributions 200 million dollars to
Cornell Medical Center now named the
Cornell Weill Medical Center a lot to
Carnegie Hall they think he's you know
really tried to help you know community
the society as well as he's made a lot
of people rich if you own Citigroup
stock you'd be a wealthy person right
now other things you write about him
he's a poor speaker yeah
you know some people say that he uses
the same 50 or 100 words in all
conversations and not only does he have
a somewhat limited vocabulary he also is
a very nervous speaker and as he is
increased in stature it's required more
public speaking and so he truly does
break out in a sweat
anytime he has to speak say he has
erratic mood swings I'm just feeding
backwards yeah I think that that's true
he's a very mercurial unpredictable
person and that's what makes them hard
to work for I think because sometimes
you don't know if you're up or you're
down with Sandy people tell me and he'll
yell at you like crazy on one day and
then the next day go act as if nothing's
happened he say he's temper tantrums and
screaming fits yeah
that's managed by gossip yeah you know
he manages by gossiper roaming around
and he you know he doesn't some CEOs
like memos and detailed analysis part of
Sandy's strength is he not only operates
on what is sound strategically but he
goes with his gut and he looks somebody
in the eye and tries to decide can I
trust this person am I can I work with
this person so he loves to roam by
managing or by gossip to get the true
story not just what's on paper because
he doesn't really operate by the written
word I mean he does not remember if I
were to walk in with the three page memo
hit turnovers like what are you here to
talk about that's the way he is a couple
of small things but incidents in the
book that I want to ask you about the
blood
incident at Greenbrier yeah over a
certian Searson Pearson and loeb rhoades
merger or something I don't know
it was you know yeah it's a big merger
he was trying to buy he's always merging
at find a bigger name a bigger company
and then plying his management skills to
the company that was a particularly
thorny it's a merger it was so huge he
was buying loeb rhoades a big name his
Shearson empire in the late 70s and I
mean everything was unraveling they
couldn't put the back offices together
people will call you say where's my
stock customers all over the nations
like where's my stock I can't find it I
mean it was like they were about to have
town and so the marketing people were
blaming the technology people they were
blaming the brokers for selling stock
when they shouldn't settle down until
the mergers in place you know it was a
blame game
he took all his executives down to
Greenbrier and they had a couple days of
golfing and drinking and light one night
you know he really wants this blood
loyalty he'll call it and so Sam took
him to heart and they went in the
kitchen and got a knife cut prick their
fingers and sold the blood of that they
would make it work they came back from
Greenbrier and pulled off what was then
such a huge merger that suddenly sandy
wilds Empire was second only to Merrill
Lynch in the 1970s and this is from a
guy who started from nothing the Augusta
National Golf Club yeah that's so
important to sandy because it is the
establishment it means you have arrived
and as you see him from the book from
starting with you know from being the
son of immigrants and his dad left home
and you know all these things that he
felt like he always had a bunch of
burdens to be admitted to Augusta
National was a big thing to Sandy he
loved it and you know who got him in was
Jim Robinson his arch enemy at American
Express Jim Robinson bested sandy at
American Express and then fast forward
20 years later who helps get him in to
Augusta Jim Robinson and because by that
point Jim Robinson has been ousted from
American Express himself and he meets
sandy wiles travelers Empire to give him
he wants to set up a venture fund and he
sandy and Sid travelers are one of his
first investors so no you see these
relationships people come and go and one
thing you'll see is sandy somehow even
though he'll blast someone or someone
will cross him these relationships come
and go and that's interesting
through the book you'll see a lot of
legends of business that he has worked
with it's funny in the end what did what
do you think of him
gosh I have a mixed opinion I think
sandy is a likable person and and and in
some ways he's very likable otherwise
he's very hard to deal with I'm not sure
I'd want to work for him I'm glad I
wrote a book and he didn't have control
of it which was an issue ongoing with
him but he gosh he's mixed I feel like
the people I interviewed so many people
I would say do you love him or hate him
and they think both I think that's what
a lot of people feel about Sandy Weill
and to me I feel I've done my job
because at the beginning I knew it
wasn't gonna be a Valentine nor a
hatchet job you know I wanted this to be
a serious biography that would be
readable so there parts of Sandy that I
liked and some parts that I don't
anybody mad at you besides and is he had
feedback on this book he's had feedback
and a lot of people tell him they've
read it and they're asking him to sign
the book that they admire him for
everything he's done you know other
people say oh my god how is this man
risen to the top with these tactics so
you know the great thing is he's a
larger-than-life personality and you can
really follow anybody else anybody else
mad at you mad at me anybody else not
like the book any best said you
misrepresented them I think not you know
even the president of Citigroup and
others called us and you know you really
nailed it
Monica Langley our guest this is what
the book looks like tearing down the
walls it's about sandy weill and
Citigroup thank you very much thank you
my pleasure